well I think we need to do two things we
depth desperately need a cap-and-trade
system I agree with that very much and
that and you know I'm glad that most of
the proposals in the Congress now for
action on climate or cap and trade
proposals I would I think the design of
that system matters as much as the
general concept does so I would hope
that we would have a system that went
very far upstream so to speak to write
when the carbon entered the economy that
it covers essentially all of the carbon
and other greenhouse gases as they you
know their sources that we auction the
allowances or the right to emit carbon
and take that money use it for good
purposes and if we do the if we do it
the right way with a you know and have
tough phase down goals it can make a
huge difference the risk is that
Congress will come along and do its
usual you know death by a thousand cuts
to this proposal these proposals and
we'll end up with something which is not
nearly as effective as it is it ought to
be that's a very real risk which is
another reason why we need a real
political a grassroots political
movement in the country there's a group
called one sky which is working with
your young people around the country and
using our well-established techniques of
community organizing to engage people on
the climate issue and I'm very proud to
have a small association with them and
I'm and I think that's that that's what
we need I'd also say though that this
regulatory approach of of cap-and-trade
needs to be supplemented by a real
expenditure of federal resources to be
sure that the programs aren't regressive
that communities that need help get help
that new industries are created that
green collar jobs are created so that it
becomes a basically a program to sustain
our communities and promote social
justice in our country at the same time
that it's a environmental program